[Music]
on Wednesday Khloe Kardashian finally
confirmed she and her beau
Tristan Thompson are expecting their
first child together it was my favorite
the reality star announced the news on
Instagram posting this pic of her
growing baby bump
but look close there's a small detail in
the photo that has fans wondering has
the couple already tied the knot
are you joking that's a ridiculous
question how can you not know check out
Khloe's left ring finger yep those are
two bands sparkling brightly tweets
started pouring in with speculation if
Ms Kardashian is now mrs. Thompson
however a source tells et Khloe is not
married explaining their quote focused
on a healthy pregnancy and did not
secretly Wed it's also worth noting the
Rings aren't new here's Chloe in May at
an upfront presentation in New York City
she also rocked a similar band in
October at the launch of her denim line
good American at Bloomingdales also in
New York City
is that crazy married or not there's no
denying how happy in love Chloe is
Tristan and I definitely talked about
starting a family he wants to have like
five or six kids
with me and that's lovely we could start
at one and we could grow from there I am
really really excited about my future
just me interest in like we're doing so
well and I'm looking forward to see
where all that goes
[Music]